in Tucson Arizona inflation has made
father of two Justin Little's grocery
shopping a lot more complicated whenever
we plan our meals we usually go to
unfortunately go to the meat first to
see what's on sale and then just kind of
have to build from there so it always
kind of depends on what is Affordable at
that time it depends on what you eat you
get to that point where you feel like
you have no choice but uh
go to the grocery store and curse later
inflation is running at an annual rate
of 8.2 percent Nationwide and even worse
here in Arizona where in some cities the
rate is 13 it's not just about food
especially with gas prices it's it's
crazy I used to fill up my tank with
like 20 bucks now it's 40. senior
citizen Lanny Betts who lives on a fixed
income is tightening his belt literally
when it comes to food we're doing all
right losing a little bit of weight so
that's a positive thing to look at
inflation is dominating the political
landscape in the days leading up to
election day with Republican candidates
hammering their Democratic opponents
claiming they are to blame for the price
of food Fuel and the cost of renting a
home polls consistently show that
inflation and the state of the economy
is the number one concern of Voters all
across the country the high cost of
living is likely to be the issue that
determines the outcome come of the
midterm elections analysts say inflation
worries are hurting Democrats in swing
States like Arizona I think inflation
nationally is a huge issue for voters
and if you're a senior citizen living on
a fixed income watching your rent go up
or watching your grocery bill go up
watching your gas bill go up
that that's something you're definitely
going to think about when you get your
ballot and you fill it out Americans
political future could hinge at least in
part on something as mundane as the
price of peanut butter
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Tucson Arizona